to try and work out what's going on i
remember i said to you here at the
beginning right there's this particular
instant of time where it gets projected
up and then everything else kind of
follows on from that okay what i want to
do is take that instead of time and
imagine it stretching out a little bit
in the same way that don't draw it in
the same way that as a team of students
and there's the extension one people
exception to people look that more
recently if i want to consider say a
volume of a solid of revolution right
essentially what i'm adding up excuse me
they are the formula of course for the
volume of this of a solid of revolution
ears can someone help me up let's
actually start with the integral first
and then we'll okay so what's in there
the pie ok I've got a new girl sometimes
they DX right this guy and this is
really PI R squared H right to remember
that what I'm adding up the whole bunch
of is these little cylinders okay but
because I can't actually draw a cylinder
of you know infinitesimally small
thickness what I do is I actually draw a
arm a cylinder that looks like it has
some actual width because I can't draw
or anything else okay so in the same way
what's happening here is at a single
instant of time like as you saw we drew
it right after instant it already
changes it's no longer following that
line anymore gravity has done something
to it which we'll talk about in a second
and has changed it but I can't draw a
single instant so instead of troy a
single is that i'm going to draw a
single second here's what I'm going to
do take that up take that projection
there right it's off an angle draw it
separately off to the side and you can
see I need to understand there's a
horizontal part of this and a vertical
part of this right and I want to try and
tease them apart so around this
projection ok I'm going to draw a box
and this box like sir helps me to
understand and work with the horizontal
and the vertical parts ok so let's
actually start putting some numbers on
this so that we can know I actually
calculate what's going on cutting back
to our original graph let's just say
an example okay I'm gonna give you a
velocity at an angle so suppose I throw
an object at the first second right it's
going at 12 meters per second just for
the first second in that whatever
direction I found in the ankle are
threaded with from from the horizontal
so this is actually an angular
inclination we go round as 60 degrees
I've just sort of done that
approximately so when you look at this
guy here it's diagram where at each of
these numbers by 60 degrees comes up
from the horizontal like that and that
12 meters per second over here the
second is over there okay so this is
going off in that particular direction
from here I want to understand that top
is per second part of it is going to be
horizontal and how it's going to be
vertical okay so how do I work out which
bits which let's imagine that this is a
whole second of motion ok so in 12
meters right Sarge in one second it's
going to travel 12 meters ok so this
along here is actually 12 I've got an
angle and I've got a right angle here as
well so therefore all I need here is
just right angle triangle tree
righteously it's simple ratios ok for
example if I want to work out this guy
down here this is the horizontal change
ok this thing happening on the bottom
axis right what is it that relates this
side of the triangle to the hypotenuse
which ratio yeah it's going to be cause
60 right coz 60 do you see that so i'm
going to write that coz 60 its adjacent
on hypotenuse right so that's going to
be X good morning next up on top does
that make sense you see how I've gotten
that number con 60 adjacent and
hypotenuse so X dot by itself is 12
times cos CC what's cost six again it's
just a half right so this is just
so the horizontal part of this motion is
6 meters per second okay at that
particular incident i'm in exactly the
same way i could work out y dot that's
this vertical change up here right what
ratio going to use this time good sign
will say why start on 12 it's opposite
on hypotenuse now is sine 60 inside 60
of course is refer to right so this is
just 6 33 33 is about one point seven
ish okay and that just corresponds to
our diagram you can see this is about
1.7 times further but this does that
make sense so you can see this is going
to be 63 center okay I in exactly the
same way going from a velocity at an
angle I can work out what's happening
horizontally and vertically but I can do
it in reverse as well so let's call this
one example one example to suppose what
I know instead of this is I know what X
star and y dot 0 from those I can work
out what the angle of projection is the
angle inclination and I can work out
what starting velocity is so draw me a
new diagram
and if for instance i happen to know 34
for instance unpadded measurement if I
know that the horizontal movement is say
15 meters per second so this is going to
be the first second of bursaries goes 15
minutes that way and then I've got a
vertical change or saying 8 meters per
second off of this I can work out what
ankle did you find that out what are you
go did you find that app and for that
whole your first second how far is it
actually moving in relation to this axis
not just vertically not just
horizontally so I can work out each of
these independently if I want for
instance if I wanted to know the angle
first what would I do what ratio
explains this it stare isn't it opposite
on adjacent so I'm going to say tan of
theta is a on 15 yeah 115 let's deal
with degrees at the moment there's uh
there's every reason to think about
radians because we could do some
calculus here but all I've doing at this
particular moment is I just want to do
the size of this angle and because I
like actually measure you things and I
know we're much more confident with
degrees and obviously there will just
get this number in degrees just like I
gave to you before can someone give it
to just to one decimal place what does
that mean 28.1 now does that seem to
make sense one of the only things i
doing things in a physical situations
you can use a sense check there's 28.1
degrees seem like a reasonable kind of
size for that angle it does right it
should because when you have a look at
when you compare these two components of
the motion play you're moving so much
further along this axis here compared to
the vertical axis most of the effort
must be thrown into a horizontal rather
than vertical what I go what I have to
throw out so the horizontal motion and
the vertical motion are exactly the same
maybe 45 degrees right because that
would make this an isosceles triangle
that make sense okay so we can work out
the angle first what do i do to work out
the actual velocity this is Pythagoras
I've got a running with triangle after
all okay at 8 15 17 defense is the it's
a it's a tray that's why people however
if it weren't such convenient numbers
we've had like turds or decimals already
kinda don't give you a life stopper you
can actually say for me in one line
because I'm just thinking about this in
a forward direction you can just give me
a one-line [ __ ] up for this right this
is Pythagoras so you would have gotten V
squared so I'm going to take a square
root of what yeah just the squares of
the two shorter sides which in this
context are the vertical and horizontal
just basically right sorry velocity
runner so that gives you the square root
of sixty-four plus I think I request my
numbers sorry the scratch your internet
9 is indeed 17 okay right excellent so
generally speaking you can see we can
use 10 to work out this we can use
Pythagoras to work out their velocity or
if what we had the first place was the
velocity and the angle you can use these
results here and you notice see how I
read this line it's like you this is
kind of like a formula right and you can
just kind of remember that at stake that
just like that up here you could write
formulas for these right if what you
wanted to get to you is just X dot and
why not straightaway right have a look
at the numbers that are the same and
have a look a little visitor or the
parts of it that are different which
parts the same that the 12 and the 60
degrees are the same right obviously
they're both dependent on these two
quantities okay so in this case you had
to multiply across so really I'm saying
X dawn is V that's the 12 costly not do
you see that right whatever the angle of
projection happens to be
and in the same way for why why not it's
going to be not V coz theta but the
slope in which it ring some bells right
it should ring some bells if you think
about this point up here as existing on
a circle that with Center at the origin
what this really is is the coordinate of
a point on the circumference of the
circle X is because there why is like we
usually say r cos theta and r sine theta
but here our radius is the velocity okay
does that make sense and also i'm going
to divide them to you again